Peter Parker lived next door to Mary Jane Watson.
Peter liked MJ a lot, but he never told her.
Peter took some photos of MJ with the spiders for the school newspaper.
"Ow! What was that?", he thought.
And there on the floor was a spider.
When he woke up, he thought, "Am I dead?"
"No!", he said.
"I feel fantastic!"
"Now," he thought, "I'm going to try this spider-webbing."
He took a line of the webbing and jumped.
"Woohoo! Now, I can fly!"
Every day, terrible things happened in New York.
Every day, Spider-Man helped people.
But who was he?
No one knew.
With great power comes great responsibility.
I'm strong and I'm a good person.
I must help other people.
You know me.
I'm Spider-Man!